hey this is preschell Walker a rectangle
contains a circle
from each corner of the rectangle
construct a tangent line to the circle
starting from the northeast corner the
lengths of the tangent lines are equal
to 46 31 34 and X
the question is to solve for the length
x
I think Akshay for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
let's get started by labeling the
diagram
call the rectangle ABCD say the circle
has Center p and label the tangent
points as e f g and H
construct triangle AEP
since AE is a tangent to the circle AE
is perpendicular to EP
since we have a right triangle a e
squared plus EP squared is equal to AP
squared
let the radius of the circle be equal to
R so that EP is equal to R
substituting in we have 46 squared plus
r squared is equal to AP squared
let's do a similar construction for the
remaining three tangent lines
construct the triangle bfp since b f is
a tangent to the circle BF is
perpendicular to FP FP is the radius of
the circle so its length is equal to R
so in this right triangle we have 31
squared plus r squared is equal to BP
squared
now construct the right triangle cgp GP
is equal to R so we have 34 squared plus
r squared is equal to CP squared
finally construct the right triangle dhp
where HP is equal to R
thus we have x squared plus r squared is
equal to DP squared
so at first it looks like we've just
made the problem more complicated
but we notice something we have a
pattern on the right hand side we have
the square of distances from each corner
to the center of the circle so let's see
if we can work out a relationship
between the squared distances
to do that we will use coordinate
geometry well let C be the origin 0 0.
let P have coordinates p q let D have
coordinates d0 and let B have coordinate
0 B
since ABCD is a rectangle a has
coordinates D comma B
now construct AP
let's calculate the squared distance of
AP
we can do the square of the distance
formula to get that this is equal to the
square of D minus P plus the square of B
minus Q
let's do the same thing for BP
the square of the distance BP is equal
to p squared plus the square of B minus
Q
do the same thing for CP this Square
distance will be equal to p squared plus
Q squared and finally we calculate the
square of the distance DP
this will be equal to the square of D
minus P plus Q squared
by simple inspection we can see that the
square of AP plus the square of CP is
equal to the square of BP Plus the
square of DP and both of these are equal
to p squared plus Q squared plus D minus
p squared plus b minus Q squared
so this gives us an equation
we now know what AP squared CP squared
BP squared and DP squared are equal to
in terms of r squared so we can
substitute in from those four equations
we've derived so we have 46 squared plus
r squared plus 34 squared plus r squared
is equal to 31 squared plus r squared
plus x squared plus r squared
we have 2R squared on both sides so we
can cancel this out
so we are left with 46 squared plus 34
squared is equal to 31 squared plus x
squared
we want X to be a non-negative length so
we will take the Don negative square
root so X is equal to the square root of
46 squared plus 34 squared minus 31
squared and that is equal to the square
root of
2311 which is approximately equal to
48.073 and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign